-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with John Oliver.
Very exciting.
We are going to be spending
New Year's Eve together.
-Yeah we are.
We're going to be doing
stand-up in Las Vegas.
-Yeah, we are.
[ Audience cheers ]
-And you've noticed
that it's very funny,
the room they have us
doing stand-up in.
-Yes, because
it's Adele's theater.
[ Laughter ]
And so for one night only Adele
ain't going to be there.
And I hope that's made
very clear
to the people that turn up
to that theater.
-And it's just you and Adele
are this Venn diagram
where just a tiny slice
of British...
[ Laughter ]
That's it. Just like...
-That's it. That's it.
That's it.
-I'm fascinated.
I mean, you do New Year's Eve
shows every year.
-Yeah, I love it.
-And you've always said
it's the best way to spend New
Year's, and you've been kind.
-Yeah, because you're not
really spending it.
You're kind of basically
doing something else instead.
It's classic
displacement activity, right?
-Yeah.
-So I love it.
I hate New Year's
as an evening, I hate it.
And so now I do stand-up,
which I love,
and they cancel each other out.
It's great.
-I'm very excited to be
doing it with you.
Our friend Brooks Wheelan
will be there as well.
-Yes, he's going to be there.
-Literally
the greatest person
to be on the road with.
You're on the road with him
all the time.
-Yeah. He's the absolute
greatest, funniest,
nicest, fantastic human being.
-Where do you think
we'll be at midnight?
-[ Laughing ]
I mean, listen,
the high-percentage guess
is back in our rooms alone.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But having --
-That's what the money --
That's what house money is on.
-House money is saying
having a nice, quiet night,
getting extra sleep
and getting an early flight
out back to our families.
I will say, having said that,
the tradition of coming
on this show
and things turning out other
than I might otherwise imagine,
there is a chance you're going
to be able to cut from this
that it's just you and me
in our underwear,
just running down the Strip,
unloading firearms in the air.
-Yeah.
-We're golden gods!
[ Cheers and applause ]
2024 is going to be great!
Pow pow!
-Pow pow! To the sphere!
[ Laughter ]
-Where's Bono?
-Yeah!
-We find him.
-We find --
-We got to find Bono.
-There's nothing worse
than an English person saying,
"Where's Bono?" with a gun
in his hand as well.
[ Laughter ]
"Bring me an Irishman!"
Yeah.
-You and I, we were --
we podcasted together.
-Yeah.
-Strike Force Five,
which I heard
very nice things about.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I didn't know if it would work
when we first started doing it.
-I was almost sure it wouldn't.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, it's a very,
very pleasant surprise
that it turned out okay.
People seem to like it.
Even if I did wonder
that some people
were listening with
a pathological interest.
"Oh, wow. Let's just see
what these five lab rats do
when they talk to each other."
[ Laughter ]
-Or talk over each other.
-That's right. Absolutely.
In many, many ways.
-My favorite thing
about the podcast was,
and I should say
we should both shout out.
We've talked about it a lot.
Jimmy Fallon
hosted episode five.
-It's a masterpiece.
It's genuinely --
-I'm so grateful to him.
I am so grateful to him
for what he gave us.
I needed those laughs
so much at that point
and only he could provide it.
It's just perfect.
-It was a very poorly run
and yet, because of that
exceptionally funny,
basically "Newlywed Game"
where Fallon texted our wives.
But we did find out super-fun
things about our wives,
including the angriest you
ever were with your wife
was when you went
to a pirate party.
-Yeah.
-Pirate-themed party.
-Yeah, because I dressed
like a pirate.
-Yeah.
-And we were there first.
And I remember
the host of the party
not really being dressed
like a pirate and thinking,
"oh, that's a shame,
but at least there's lots of
pirates coming."
[ Laughter ]
Then...
Then another couple turn up.
Very much not pirate-based,
and I'm getting a sinking
feeling in my stomach
saying, "The third one
will be the key here."
Not dressed like a pirate.
And I really was dressed,
like, very much like a pirate.
-Yeah.
-So I spent a pretty angry
afternoon and evening dressed
like a pirate among non-pirates.
-Now, I also want to stress.
I want to say even if everybody
dressed like a pirate...
-Yes.
-...I'm going to go out
on a limb and say you would
have hated that.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Oh, the evening was not
going to go great for me,
but at least I wanted to be able
to be among other pirates,
and I really wasn't.
I was among people dressed
in kind of casual way.
-And this is a photo
of you and your wife.
And I do want to note
she's having a grand old time,
and you are the unhappiest
I've ever seen a pirate.
-Now, you say that.
[ Laughter ]
You say that.
I would say...
[ Laughs ]
I would say
a pirate on a pirate ship
would look that unhappy
if none of the other pirates
were dressed like pirates.
[ Laughter ]
-If it was like Casual Friday
on Pirates of the Caribbean.
-That's right. Exactly.
You go, "Hey, guys.
Guys, you have to let me know.
I've pirated up over here.
You can't hang me out
to dry like this. Arrr."
[ Laughter ]
-Also an eyepatch
is even funnier
when the pirate's
wearing glasses.
[ Laughter ]
-That is such a --
And if you're wondering, is
an eyepatch more comfortable
over the glasses
or under the glasses?
It's a coin flip.
You just have to rotate.
Neither is good.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, God love Kate.
Also, it does feel like Kate's
goatee is also an eye patch.
-Yes. That's right.
-It does feel like you guys
bought a thing of iPads
and you're like,
"We got to use them all."
[ Laughter ]
Whether it makes sense or not.
-That's right.
Yeah. That's right.
Also, I just think
she could get away
with it more than me.
I don't know if it's the belt.
If it's the Pirates
of the Caribbean.
-Oh, everybody who's
seen this photo thinks that.
[ Laughter ]
You're like,
"Also, I'm going to say
something you guys
might not have clocked.
Kate makes a great pirate."
Yeah. No. We're there.
[ Laughter ]
I can't wait for
New Year's Eve, buddy,
and hopefully
I'll see you before that.
-I know. I never
thought I'd say that.
-Yeah. No kidding.
John Oliver, everybody.
"Last Week Tonight"
Sundays on HBO, streams on Max.
We'll be right back with
Aaron Jackson and Josh Sharp.